はい それではよろしくお願いします
はい 今日のお話のテーマは
お釈迦様はなぜ出家されたのかっていうこと
えーと まあこれはまあよく聞かれる質問で
まあ私たちにもよく聞かれますね
なんでまたあなたは出家したんですか？と
私に聞く場合は もしかするとね
なんでこの人はというのを思っているかもしれませんね
全くも不祥しくない人がなんで出家したのかという意味で聞いているかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり お釈迦様などなど
他のたくさん方々が出家なさったので
それはどういうことかということはだいたいよく興味のある質問になっています
はい それから順番で話を進めていきたいと思います
この質問の答えと一緒に
私は仏教を紹介するという仕事もございますので
仏教というどういうものかとも理解しつつ
その質問の答えを探し探ります
まず なぜ生きるのかという課題があります
なぜ生きるのかという
生きる目的は何なのですか？と
何のために生きるのですか？命とは何ですか？と
生かされているのですか？と
命とは自然の流れで突然起きた出来事ですか？と
命が先ですか？宇宙が先ですか？と
先に現れたのは命ですか？あるいは宇宙ですか？と
まあ現代人はあまりそこはおかしいと思うかもしれませんだけど
昔はそうではなかったんです
現代人が宇宙が先で生命が後やと思ってますけど
神様を信仰している場合は
やっぱり生命は先で宇宙は後になっちゃいます
だって神様が前からいるんだからね
宇宙が現れる前から 死とは何ですか？死後はあるか否か
そういう風に命に関わる質問というのはたくさんあります
なんとかわかりやすい質問をいくつか出しましたけど
まだまだたくさんあります
しかし いまだに納得いける答えは見つかりません
昔から  西洋のことはあまり私は知りませんだけど
インド文化ではもうかなり紀元前 2000年
3000年前からもそういう疑問を持っていたんですね
ですから そこまで長い間人間が考えて考えているんですけど
どうもなかなか 答えがないんですね
答えはあるんだけど もう一つという
だからその答えに対立して
誰かが別な答え出すんですよ
例えば 生きる目的は何ですかということには
まあインドではね まあ運命論を教えた宗教組織がありまして
運命 定め 決まり まあ設定しているんだと
すべて固定しているんだと
で 一切はすべて固定しているならば
あえて生きる目的ということは成り立たないんですね
ただ 今世で自分の役割を果たせばそれで十分やと
現在 現代のヒンドゥー教も前と違って
そういう神が作ったものだから
まあ神が決まっているんだと
何するべきかということは
だから我々はギャーギャー言わず
自分の人生を生きてみればいいんじゃないかというふうな考えもありますよ
そういう だからといって
我々は馬鹿みたく運命に人生を任せて生きていていいのかというね
疑問もまた反論が成り立つのですよ
あるいは神を信仰しない人々は頑張ったらどうですか？と
自分で人生をね 改良改革したらいかがですか？というふうに疑問を持ったりする可能性もありますね
だから生きる目的と何のために生きるのか
なんか似ていてね まあ似ているんですけど
生きる目的っていうのはもうちょっとスケールが大きいんですね
最終的にどんなゴールを目指して生きるのかっていう
何のために生きるのかといえば
まあそれほどスケールが大きくなくて
まあちょっと何のためかっていうぐらいのことなんですね
それから誰でも命っていう言葉を使ってますけど
その一体この命って何なのかと
全然誰もわかってないんですよ
よく喋りますけどね もう命を神様に入れてくれたとかね
それが何ですかと まあ精霊という話もありまして
全然わかってないんですよ
解剖して分解して こういうことだと全然もう発見してもないんで
いまだに まあ一応信仰しているだけ
すごいもう現代人やとか
IT 時代やとか あれこれと言っている言っている割にはすごい石器時代の原始人と同じく
まあとにかく信仰すると
だから神様の精霊だから
これ遺体は燃やしてはならんと未だに思っていて
埋葬する だから矛盾ありますよ
そんなに不死なる霊魂があるならば
まあちょっとしたもう遺体ぐらい燃やしたってもね
もう霊まで燃えてしまうという
大した霊じゃないんですね
それだったら大した魂ではなくなるんですね
それでもイギリスやらアメリカやらね
まあもうお墓を作る場所がなくなっちゃって
じゃあ燃やしてもいいということにしているんです
それで自分の都合で論理作るんですよ
もう永遠なものはもうもう永遠でない火で燃えませんと
ではもう火葬してもよろしいということに
随分勝手に決めるんですが
いまだにローマ教会の人々はまあ火葬はしませんけど
それから生かされているのですかということ
だから命は何なのか まださっぱりわからない
生かされているのかというと
そうそうだと思う人もいて
いい 我は生きているんだというふうな思う人もいるんですね
それは人の思考次第なんですね
まあ自分が勝手にあれやります
これやりますと思ったっても
そうできないでしょうと
いう人々もいる それから科学思考に乗っている人々は
まあこの自然の流れで
命っていうのは突然現れてきたんだと
で 神との関係は 全くないというふうに激しく言っている人々もいますね
地球がね 出てきて もう激しく雨が降ったり
雷が落ちたり いろんなことがあって
ごちゃごちゃごちゃ混ぜて
それでまあ自然発生でアミノ酸が出てきたんだと
それで生命が誕生しました
だからそういう説明ではアミノ酸が生命ということになりますけど
本当にアミノ酸は生命でしょうかって
またまた聞きたくはなりますね
まあ命は先ですかっていうことは説明しましたからね
それから人の死というどういうことでしょうかと
また疑問にしているんですね
はい そういうことで 命に関わるたくさん疑問
知りたいこと 人間が持っている
昔から しかし いまだに納得いくしっかりした答えはないんです
仏教は全部答えを持ってますけどね
それは納得いかないとは言えないんです
皆 自分の意見を事実だと述べているんですね
この納得いかない理由は
自分の意見をね 自分の気持ちを真理として言ってるだけ
例えば 私が死んでも死にたくないと
もう永遠に生き続けたいという気持ちがあったら
平気で魂っていうのはね
死にませんよと 人が死んでもと平気で言っちゃいますよ
そうすると聞く人々は
あ そうですか よくわかりましたと
わかってないんですけど
よくよく見るとその人の気持ち言ってるだけなんです
証拠あるのかとね 人間が何か証拠あるのかと聞く
聞かないんですね 怖いと思ってるんですね
大体証拠あるのかと聞いた方がいいと思いますよ
はい そういうわけで 考えても答えが出ないんです
人間の思考は正確ではありません
問題はそれなんです 人間の思考っていうのは決して正確ではありません
ます気持ち 好み 感情などのバイアスの膜があるんです
我々はいくら考えても
自分の気持ち 自分の感情
自分の好み 全部同じことですけど
そういう膜が入ってるんですね
思考に これ バイアスが入ってるんですね
だからバイアスで考えるのは正確には正確的な思考ということは言えないんです
それで終わらないんです
他人に言われたこと 教えられたことをもとにして考えるというバイアスがあります
また 我々みんな学ぶでしょう
いろんな人から学ぶんですね
親はじめ 学校の先生やら社会人やら
いろんな人 新聞 雑誌などなどからも
我々は学ぶは学ぶは学ぶはデータをもうものすごく入れちゃいますね
それから考える場合は
その膜から考えちゃうんです
これ かなりきついんですよ
教えられた通りに考えるといえば
まあそれがかなりのバイアスですよ
次 この文化 習慣 信仰などのバイアスがあるんですね
その上 文化的に思考が変わるんですよ
人間というのはもうものすごい文化もいろいろ
日本文化といっても 沖縄の沖縄文化があって
青森の青森の文化があるんですよ
困ったもんです 同じじゃないんです
で それでそれぞれの国に行けば
それぞれの地方に見れば
それぞれの文化があって
そちらの人々は自分なりの思考をしているんです
中国のどこかの山の方の人々は
日本人と同じく考えるわけじゃありません
違います だから文化 それから信仰
何か信仰すると 何でもかんでもこの信仰の膜を通して考えるんですね
その習慣というのも同じことで
文化と似ていますけど
習慣になったら習慣でも考えたりする
次 唯物主義思考 現代科学思考というバイアスがあります
これもバイアスなんですよ
で 一番頭のあまりややこしいことを考えたくないという人々は唯物論になるんですね
その方がもうどんな無知な人に分かります
例えば人が死んじゃったらそれで終わるでしょうに
遺体はまあそれで燃やして壊れていくでしょうにと
死後っていうのは 死後っていうのは灰だけやと
言うのは簡単ですよ 有備推論だから
死後の世界ありますか？あります
灰になりますと 人が死んだら
あるいは骨だけ残りますよと
死後は だから死後は骨ですと言えば随分わかりやすいでしょうに
だから有備推論的に我々の思考パターンを変えると
そこはバイアスになります
それで科学を学んだらもう宗教になるんですね
科学っていうものは 科学は未だにいい加減で不完全で
どうったことはないんですよ
そんなに真剣性ミスってことはないんで
ただふざけて遊んでるだけなんです
科学者っていうのは 金はいくらでもあるし
一般人の食べるためにある金がね
これ使っても じゃあ試しにロケットでも売ってやりましょうとかね
もう三百億ぐらいお金かかっちゃいますけどね
あの人々のもうおもちゃ遊びですけど
まあそんな程度の科学なんですけど
やっぱりちょっと勉強してみると
これって結構難しいんですね
科学はものすごい小さな小さな分野に分けてありまして
これ一つしか勉強できないし
そうなってくると その人の信仰がその自分が勉強した科学分野になってしまいますね
だから何を考えても自由に考えることはできなくなるんです
その尺度で考えるんだから
科学さえもバイアスなんです
なのに自由で客観的な思考ないのは
それで我々にないのは自由な思考はないんです
自由思考はない 客観的な思考は同じことです
自由と客観的ってのはただ言葉を繰り返しただけで
で 客観的な思考だけはないんです
思考はあるんですよね
みんなよく深く考えてますよ
あの法然心教の観音さんみたいにね
深く考えるんだけど それからごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃいい加減ですからね
今日 法然心教は 単純論理も崩れているという
だからみんな深くは考えますけど
自由思想がないんですね
客観的な思想がそれだけないんです
というわけで 思考は我々には答えを持っ出さないんですね
というわけで なぜ生きるのか
生きる目的は何でしょうか？という問いに何の答えも現れないんです
まあ今日は仏教的な答えを出すのは全然構わないんだけど
もうテーマはちょっと脱線してしまいますので
答えはできるだけ控えます
皆 単純な意見だけを述べている
この大事な問題について
単純に意見だけ述べて
それで終了ということになるんです
ではないかで終わっちゃうんですね
何でも 何のために生きるんでしょうかといったら
まあなんだらかんだらではないんですかねとかね
結婚して子供を作るためではないんでしょうかとかね
例えば生物学者に聞けば
あ それは自然を子孫を作るためではないんですかとかね
生物学者であっても 生命の目的は子孫を作ることですと言えないんですよ
だってそういう証拠がないんだから
証拠は必死で子孫を育てていることは見えますけど
それが目的なのかと そういうわけで
命に関わるどんな質問にも
我々はではないかで終わっちゃいます
神様に創造されたんではないかと
あるいは自然発生ではないかと
例えば宇宙がね 初期時代でいろいろ変化があって
アミノ酸が誕生しましたということも
まだまだ証拠が出ていないんです
そういう考えもあるということで
だから科学者もまあそれでこれでこうではないかというところなんですね
だからそれと神様が初めてアダムとイブが創りましたという話って
それほど質に質の差がないんです
生きることは些細な出来事ですかと
そんなにいい加減に自分の意見を出してではないかということを出して
それからそのではないかで生きてみるでしょうに
あまりにもふざけているでしょ
我々は 命に対して 神様に創られたんではないか
ではないかと それから神様にも一生懸命もう歌ったり
讃嘆讃美歌を歌ったり
言われる通りにしたりして
なんか人生そんなに些細なものですかね
そんなふざける ふざけて生きていいんですかね
例えば唯物論者がね まあ死んだら残るのは骨だけですからと
それからふざけて生きているでしょうに
あるいは運命論者がね
まあ全部決まっているんだからね
何が起きたっても全部決まっている
なるようにしかなりませんと
あれは運命論者のスローガンなんですね
なるようにしかなれませんと
そういう人っていうのはふざけて生きているでしょうに
そんなにも命っていうのは些細などうでもいいことですかね
人にとっては生きること以外大事なものはないはぜです
自分が生きているということほど大事な価値のある
価値と置きましょう 置いておきましょう
とにかく自分にとってはこれがもうこの上ない大事なものなんです
生きているんだということ
これ 認めないんですね
おかしいんです 我々は何を評価しても
何をやっても 命が先大事なんですよ
この自己犠牲で生きている人々はいませんよ
アホ以外は 人を助けたい気持ちはありますよ
良いことをしたいとかね
苦しんでいる人々を助けてあげたいと
病気で苦しんで伝染病で死にかけている人々に
なんとかしたいと思っている人々はいくらでもいますよ
しかし 自分を犠牲にして十字架に打たれてほしいという人が
アホ以外はいないと思いますよ
この受難というのはもう完全な無知な思考なんです
誰でも自分の命を大事にするんです
気をつけるんです 怪我しないように
死なないようにと 何をやっても
だから我々はやりたくないものでも
包丁を後ろから刺しちゃえばね
やっちゃいますよ あるいはピストルでもね
後ろにつけて殺しますからね
あれこれやりなさいと言うとやりますよ
普段やりたくないことさえ
なぜかというと 命がやっぱり大事なんですよ
だから客観的に見ると
生命の生き方を見ると
どんな生命でも自分の命を大事にしているんですが
すごい些細なものの扱いなんですね
そうではないかという哲学で生きているんだから
ふざけて 無視できるどうでもよい些細な出来事ではありません
何よりも生きることは先に来るはずなんです
なぜ説明しまったから飛ばします
しかし 生きる目的はわからないといえば
命は些細なものになります
生きる目的がわからないというと
結局は命というのは些細なものやということになるんですよ
人間というか 生命っていうのは本当に怖いものなんですよ
自分の命は大事ですけど
他人の命は些細なものやと思いますよ
全然もうへっちゃらですね
だってイケス作るっていう風な食べ物の食事習慣まであるでしょ
いかに残酷で恐ろしいかというと
命に対してみじんももう他人の命に対しては
価値観を入れてないんですよ
大量大量やと言ってね
大量に命を取ったりして
生き物やと我々と同じく生きていたがっている生命やと
それはもうみじんも思わない
大量大量あって漁をやってる人々が
ちょっと激しい波が来て
船がちょっと 動きがおかしくなったところで
あるいはもうちょっとその日で戻れなくなっただけで
もう大変大げさ 自分が何千の命も取っているのに
船の中にいるのはせいぜい 10人ぐらいでしょうに
だから これ人間だけじゃないんですよ
他の動物も同じなんです
自分の命はすごい大事にするんだけど
他の生命体ってのは全然気にもしない
取りたい放題取っちゃう
この鳥たちを見てください
もう雛が生まれてくると
もう他の生き物を取るは取るは取るは取って取って自分の雛に食わせる
だから 1匹の雛を育てるために
どれぐらい生命を なくなってしまうのかと
大変ですよ それから 自分の命だけ大事だと思っていたっても
生きる目的はわからないと言った途端
自分の命が些細なものにもしているんです
はい 答えあります もし命とはかけがえのない大事な出来事であるならば
生きる目的は何よりも明確に知っているはずです
命っていうのは もうかけがえのない
とても尊い とてももう
究極に価値のあるすごいことであるならば
何のために生きているのかということを知っているはずなんです
一人一人が でも 他の宇宙は丸いか四角いは知ってるんだけど
自分が何のために生きているのかってことを知らないでしょ
日本の歴史ではね もうもう天皇は何人いたんですか？名前はなんで全部リスト暗記して言えるんだけどね
私には聞かないと私知りません
今 平成何年でわかりません
あまり ではなくて 皆様は学校ではね
ちゃんと丸暗記してそれ知ってますけど
自分が何のために生きるのかで
これ知らないんです おかしいんですよ
命より天皇陛下の名前のリストが大事ですかね
おかしいんじゃないんですかね
アレクサンダー大王は何やったのかと聞いたら
ものの見事に言うでしょうに
クレオパトラ パトラのもう食べ物は何でしたか？とかね
どんな酒飲んだのかとかね
どんなアクセサリーつけていたのかといったら
ものの見事に言う あなたは何のために生きているのかって
そんなの知りませんと
何ですかね これは そういうわけで
命ということはすごい大事な尊いものであるならば
生きる目的っていうのは知ってるはずなんです
目的があって生きているのではないんです
だから それ答えです だって
みんなそうでしょうに
過去の人間も 過去の生命も
現在生きている生命も
誰一人も目的があって生きていないんですよ
だから一人も見つからないならば
目的があって生きる生命は
100人に一人じゃないでしょうに
1万生命に一人じゃないでしょうに
無数の生命でしょうに
地球だけの生命を考えても
宇宙の生命は置いておきましょう
仏教は宇宙にもすごい生命がいると
ものすごいたくさんいるとは
もうありますけどもね
それは置いておいて 地球だけ見ても
どれほど生命がいるんですかね
その無数の生命の中で
一人でも一つの生命でも
我はこんな目的で生きてるんだということはありますかね
ないでしょう ということは
生命は生きる目的がなく生きているということが答えです
以上 バイアスがなければ発見する答えです
バイアスがなければ いたは簡単にその答え見えてくるんです
私はその答えをいろんな講演で出してますよ
生きることに目的はありませんと
みんなへーという反応なんですね
私はふざけているんだと
いつでも悪口ばっかしね
辛口ばっかし言ってるんだから
これももう一つのね そんなに真剣に聞く必要がない辛口やと思ったりしますけど
しかし バイアスがなければ
あ なるほど それが事実やと
事実です 現実です 目的があって生きているわけではないんです
はい ちょっと脱線します
話はジャータカ物語などなど
何人かの方々でも読まれたことはあると思いますね
菩薩という言葉がありますね
お釈迦様がかなり昔からね
あの数字が我々の言葉で覚えていますけど
あれは日本語にするとどんな数字なのかちょっとわからない
勉強不足でね だからまあかなり前というね
言ってしまいますけど
もうものすごい無数の過去
あの古単位で宇宙現れて消えて現れて消えて
そういう回数を無数 そういう遠いところからも
お釈迦様が菩薩として修行を積んできたんだと
どこへ生まれても あのハラミットというね
パーラミタとパーリ語で言うんですね
そういうものを完成しましたと
その話が出る場合に限って生きる目的があるんです
この今のお釈迦様より先
2 4番目では 28番目
24番目のディーパンカラというブッダが遠い遠い遠い遠い遠い昔ということ
この宇宙がある昔ではなくて
もう無数のもう前なんですね
宇宙から計算しても ディーパンカラというブッダがいましたと
名前だけ現代人使う名前をつけてあげますよ
でなきゃもう伝えられませんだからね
そのブッダのところで
スメーラというある修行者が
ブッダの威力を見て すごい方やと
私もこのようなブッダになりたいと
と祈願するんです そうすると
ディーパンカラブッダがこの人の性格を見て
徳を見て あ これこれぐらい条件が揃っているならば
この希望が叶いますよと言って
確かにあなたはこれこれぐらいの時間経たところでブッダになりますと
と予言する はい それでその菩薩のスメーラ菩薩の人生は決めたんです
目的が設定したんです
それから無数に輪廻転生しながら
その目的に達成するために生きてきたんです
だから菩薩はどこに生まれても何か一つを能力を獲得するんです
人格の だからブッダには敵わないんです
計画通りに生きる人と人とどうでもいいと生きている人っていうのは違いますよ
我々の生き方を見ても
どんなくだらないことであっても
私はこれしっかりやるぞと計画を立てると
その人はそのために生きるんですよ
そうすると他の人に敵わないんですよ
びっくりするほど能力上がるんです
フラダンスをやってやるぞと思ったら
まあ初めは腰が痛いかもしれませんし
膝もあまり曲がらないかもしれない
それでも決めたら毎日毎日練習して
まあフラダンス大会に出て
何て言いますか なんて言いますか
この賞を取るところはできるまで行く可能性ありますよ
そうすると このいい加減ふざけてきている人には敵わないんです
だからお釈迦様がかなり昔から計画で生きてきたんですね
だから生きる目的あるのは菩薩として修行する人々なんです
しかし 菩薩の概念は 皆様が知っている日本の菩薩の概念とは違います
日本の菩薩概念がかなり湾曲というかね
理屈から脱出して屁理屈にしているんです
屁理屈でなければ理解できないという人間のすごいいいところもありますからね
論理的に喋ると あなたの話は無茶苦茶でわかりませんって言うんですね
屁理屈を喋ると よく口を開けて聞いているんです
時々私は皆様気づかないようにそういう実験もしてみますよ
わざと理屈くずして喋ってると
みんなよく口を開けてその時だけ聞いてるんです
だからこの大乗仏教世界では菩薩っていうのは
この如来がいて 如来が変身するんですね
一般の人々と何とか関わり持ちたいと
で 人を救ってあげたいんだと
そういう風に あの如来から変身するものであってね
菩薩はちょっとそれならおかしいんですね
で なんで如来直々来て人助けないんですかね
怖いんですかね 観音さんに任かって観音さんとして変身してくる来るのはね
まあそんなこと言ったら私は屁理屈しゃべると思いますからね
だから論理をしゃべるのやめます
はい それでこの生きる目的がないというポイントについてちょっと脱線した話なんですね
私たちの初期仏教では
菩薩にだけ生きる目的があるんです
ふざけて生きてるわけじゃないんです
その他は一切の生命はただ生きているだけ
ですから 客観的に物事を見るならば
生命は目的がなく生きているということが答えになるんです
だから これ 命が些細ということには関係なくなっちゃうんです
命は大事であろうか 些細なものであろうか
それと関係なく 生命は目的がなく生きているということになるんです
ですから ただ生きるということなんです
事実を認めましょう 人はなぜ生きるかと知って生きているわけではありません
人は死ぬことは怯えて
死を避ける目的で生きるのです
それははっきりしています
勉強も仕事も その他のことも
生きるために行っているんです
生きるためということは
生きるためにやっているということは
死なないためにやっているという意味なんです
はっきりしているでしょう
生命は死にたくないんですよね
だからみんな必死で何をやっているのかというと
死なないために あれこれとカラクリをやっているんです
ごまかしやっているんです
死なないために それで一体私は何の目的で生きているのかとまた疑問までする
もう頭おかしいんですよ
はっきりしているんだから
死なないために生きているだけです
勉強することも 仕事をすることでも
研究することでも スポーツやることでも
ちょっとおかしい ごちゃごちゃなんですけど
よく見るとすべて死なないためにやっているんです
そのスポーツマンになったら
何か自分には立場があるんですよ
収入もあります それで生きていられますということなんです
芸術は好きで 人々に感動を与えたくて音楽芸術やってる人はいませんよ
人に十分感動を与えることができたら
自分が売れるんだと それで自分が生きていられるんだということがはっきりしています
そういうわけです だからまあ
命は死なないために生きているだけです
死を避けることなら何でもやります
ということで はい 次のポイントに入ります
ちょっと頭の中整理整頓してください
かなり微妙なポイントを進んでいきますからね
ずいぶん軽く聞こえるんだけど
これ大変な話なんです
生きる目的はありません
というか 調べてみると目的があって生きていないんです
それで生きる目的はないんだということになるんです
それから それでもなんで必死なのかというと
一切の生命は死を避けたいんですよ
死にたくないんですよ
だから呼吸しているんです
だからご飯を食べてるんです
しかし 次どうなるのかと
生きることは好きだからこそ死を避けるんです
好きなんです 生きることは
ミミズはミミズでいることは好きなんです
カニはカニでいることは好きなんです
カニは決して魚を見て
ああ 俺も魚になりたいなとは思うないんです
アホなことを妄想するのは人間だけだからね
私も鳥になりたいとかね
これ頭が悪いのは人間に決まってますからね
動物はそこまでは思わないと思います
ですから ゴキブリはゴキブリの人生は好きなんです
私は嫌われ者だから自殺してやりますと
ないんです 殺虫剤をかけようと思うと
もう逃げるんです だからいろいろ生命
命に関わるいろいろポイントがあるんですよ
これ 誰も発見しないんですよ
お釈迦様以外は 一つは命が好きということ
生きていきたい 何があっても生きていきたいんです
命が好きなんです だから死を避けるんですよ
死んだ時点でもう生きていないんだから
だから これだけにみんなすべての力を絞ってます
死を避ける たった一言葉に
我々は全能力をそちらにかけているんです
これは生きることに対する強烈な執着です
好きだから執着が生まれてくるんです
生きることに これってかなりたちが悪くてどうにもならないんですよ
この執着はなんで生まれたのでしょうかね
それほど執着して命を守ろうとするのは
結局はいたも簡単にあっけなく死んでしまうからです
もうわかるでしょう そんなにも必死で生きることに執着しているのは
あっけなく死ぬんです
ちょっと呼吸止めただけでも死にます
ちょっとあのメキシコでね
ちょっとインフルエンザにかかっただけですけど
もうかなりもう人々が死んでいるんです
大変怖いんです 状況は
あのバードフルーというね
鳥インフルエンザありましたね
これでも人々は結構死にましたけど
次 スワインフルーという豚インフルエンザというものが現れてきて
じゃあ次にどんなインフルエンザかとかわかりませんだけどね
それが人間に感染して
それだけのことで ウイルスに感染しただけで死にますよ
これほど我々の体の中で体を守る細胞が大量にあるのに
白血球でしたっけ？あの
あの T 細胞って言ってね
白血球の中でも細菌を殺すという
あのキラーセルと英語で言いますけどね
殺し屋 我々の体で無数にそういう細胞はあるのに
もうちょっと変わった
ほんのちょっとのちょっとしたウイルスが入ったらもうお手上げ
あのエイズウイルスというものがあるんですね
あれ ウイルスの中でもなんかすっごい弱いみたい
話によると ものすごく弱いみたい
例えば空気感染はしないし
体に触れたっても全然何のこともないし
ちょっと石鹸で洗っただけでもう死んでしまうし
なのに薬効かない 体に入ったらもうさようならっていうこと
だから我々の命っていうのはあっけなく死ぬんですよ
階段で足がちょっとこけただけで十分です
ちょっと頭が何かに打っただけで
もう命は終わりという
これが人間の命だけではなくて
どんな生命の命も同じことなんですよ
体格の象さんにしたっても
まあ風邪ひいただけで肺炎で死ぬ可能性はあります
命はすごく脆いんです
しかし 生きていきたいでしょ
だから強烈に執着して守るんです
女性の方々は 自分が産んだ子供に執着するでしょ
ものすごい強烈 で 微妙
自分の命にある執着ほどはないんですけど
まあある程度では執着する
命に対する執着はもうすごいんです
それでなんで自分の子供にすっごく大事に守ってガードして
恐ろしい鬼になって子供を守るのかというと
子供はすっごく弱いんです
赤ちゃんが 一人で何もできないんです
何一つもできない ちょっとしたことで死んでしまいます
だから命がもろいんだから
赤ちゃんの 大変危険だから
一人で何もできないんだから
自然法則で母親がものすごい子供に執着するんです
面倒見と面倒見を面倒見を守ろう
守ろう 守ろうということ
一般的に人間も子供に対しては優しいっていうのは一般的な感情なんですね
大人と比較すると子供は弱いんです
誰かに守ってもらわないと生きていられないんです
誰かがご飯を食べさせて
身の回りの面倒を見てあげて
寝かしてあげないと ガードマン
誰かがついてないと 子供には一人では生活できません
だから我々大人の社会は
まあ一般的には子供に対しては大変守ってあげるということでなっちゃうんです
それ 弱いんだからなんです
それで 自分の命があっけなく死んでしまう弱いものだから
自分が自分の命に強烈に執着するんです
生きるための戦いで疲れたり
失敗したり 希望通りにいかなかったりするとき
やりたくはないことをやらされたりするとき
なぜ生きるのか 生きる目的は何？と思う人はいます
そこでポイントはちょっとまた変わってきます
我々は必死で生きることに執着していて
とにかく生きていきたい
とにかく生きていきたいという唯一な希望で生きています
それに勉強するは 仕事をするは
スポーツもするわ テニスもやるわ
散歩もするわ おしゃれな服も着るわ
お化粧もするわ 何でもする
生きているために 人々とは仲良くする
自分の命を守るために
そんなことやっても いつでもうまくいくという保証はないんですよ
勉強しようと思ったんだけど
いろいろ条件が揃わなくて勉強できなくなったとか
友達作ろうと思ったんだけど
うまくいかなかった 失敗してしまったと
仕事をしようと思ってますけど
就いた仕事はなかなかできなくなったと
そういうこともありますね
世の中で それでいるんですね
何やっても失敗するという
何一つうまくできない人間もいます
そういう人々ですよ 一体生きる目的って何ですか？と考えているのは
他の人々は考えてないでしょ
勉強うまくできたと ちゃんと仕事にも就いたと
仕事は問題なく行ってるんだと
結婚もできたと 子供もいるんだと
そういう人は 我々は私は一体何のために生きているの？全然思わないんです
だから 死なないための努力は
ちょこちょこっとガタガタになると
うまく進めなくなると
一体人って生きて生きているもの
生きている意味はなんでしょうか？命って何でしょうか
あれやこれやとか考えたりはするんです
はい ですから 最大の疑問は
生きる能力が足らない人の問題になるんです
人間にとって遠い昔から考えてきたこの最大の疑問類が能力のない人の疑問なんです
遠い昔 インドでももう畑やって
もうそれなりにも野菜作って
もう生活していた人はそんなことを聞かなかったんです
なんで生きてるの？そんなこと考えてる暇がないんですよ
さっさと畑作らなくちゃいけないし
野菜が採る時期になってくると
早く行って取らないと動物に食べられるし
そこで野菜を持って家に戻ったらね
もう疲れているし そこはいろいろ保存したり
いろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないし
何のために生きるのか
そんなことくだらんこと考えてなかったんです
だから紀元 3000年前ででも
そういう問題考えた人々っていうのはね
相当失敗者やと思いますよ
まあ断言的に皆っていうことはね
どうせ我々の世界ではね
それは言えませんだけど
もうかなりの量  9割ぐらいはアホな連中の考え方やと思います
失敗者の だからですよ
哲学読んでみたっても
この人は相当頭がイカれてるんだっていうことになるでしょうね
だってどうでもいいことを言うために分厚い本を書くんです
ですから 答えも当てにならないんでしょうに
たわ言に過ぎないんです
そういうわけで 結構派手なことを言いますけど
命についてあれやこれやと
ウパニシャッド哲学やらヴェーダ聖典やらアヴェスタやらいろいろあるでしょうに
あんなのは戯言なんです
聖書とか何だらかんだらとかね
コーランとかね じゃあ何か大事なことあるのかと
ないんですよ ただ 皆様にはバイアスが入っているんだから
そんなことを怖くて言えないだけです
あのモーセさんにしたっても
もう大変でしたから 人生は
うまくいかないがね 人様
それでいろいろからくりやったというね
マジック禁則やったという話もありますけど
いろいろことをやったり
脅し文句を紙とかなんだらかんだらとかね
持ってきて   2000年ずっと人を騙しています
2000年じゃないね 4000
年になりますね そういうわけで
この普通に仕事が忙しくて
子供に食べるものを探すのは忙しい
それまたうまくいったりして
そういう人々は考えないんです
生きることは何なのかどうかね
頑張っても頑張っても
子供はお腹が空いて泣いている
自分がなんとか食べ物を探しても探してきますと
出て行って 山に入っても
森に入っても 人に何か仕事あったらくださいと
その代わりに米ちょっとちょうだいと
今日はもう何も仕事ないんだよと言われると
家にも戻りたくない 山に入っても何もない
やっぱり考えますよ その時は何なのか
一体この命はと すごい自然な流れでしょ
で 遠い昔のことを考えなくても
日本の皆様の間でも 何のために生きるのかと疑問する人々はみんな失敗者でしょ
どこかでこけてます すり抜けてます
はい